but catch a falling star 60 years ago
this week Perry Como made music history
the crooners single to catch a falling
star became the first song to be awarded
the gold record the Recording Industry
Association of America conceived the
gold record to honor artists and track
sales but the records have come to
represent success in the music industry
to be awarded a gold record an artist
has to sell half a million units of a
single song or album since that first
gold record in 1958 more than six
thousand singles and nine thousand
albums have achieved gold status from
the Beatles to the Jackson 5 and the
gold one will hold in the meantime I
sure hope so ladies and gentlemen our
thanks to the Jackson 5
[Music]
when the night the lights went out in
Georgia reached gold status in 1975
singer Vicki Lawrence was surprised with
her record on CBS's The Carol Burnett
Show the awards cost about three hundred
and fifty dollars apiece and they're not
made from actual gold but to the artists
who were not only the gold record is a
milestone on their musical journey that
is big we've gotten a lot bigger and a
lot more elaborate over the years but
Carol Burnett should still hand them out
wouldn't it be great to get your gold
record from Carol Brodie thank